puede que los soldados rusos hayan
abandonado esta localidad situada a 70
kilómetros de kiev pero el trauma de
semanas de ataques aún lo sienten los
residentes de aquí
anna cuyo nombre ha sido modificado para
proteger su identidad es una de las
tantas mujeres que han acusado a las
tropas rusas de usar la violación como
un arma de guerra ella narra que fue
violada por un soldado mientras que su
marido fue asesinado cuando intentaba
salvarla
sentí miedo
el soldado me tomó de prisionera me dijo
quítate la ropa o te dispararé después
de que los soldados se fueron de mi casa
y contra drogas pegamento y viagra
los desgarradores relatos de violencia
sexual a manos de las tropas rusas
parecen no tener fin la vecina de anna
dice que el mismo soldado abuso y mató a
otra mujer su casa convertida en
escenario del crimen está cubierta de
manchas de sangre
los soldados rusos me dijeron que la
habían violado y que le habían cortado
la garganta o la habían apuñalado y que
se había desangrado dijeron que había
mucha sangre
y la cercana ciudad de mucha historia
desgarradoras similares recibes que
ocupa aunque porque nuevo mucho esto fue
después de que los ocupantes rusos
hubieran abandonado mucha alrededor de
25 niños y mujeres de entre 14 y 24 años
fueron violadas una mujer de 25 años nos
llamó para que la ayudáramos
y su hermana de 16 años que fue violada
por esos rusos justo en la calle
y
el lunes el presidente de la strada
ucrania una organización de derechos
humanos informó a la onu de otros casos
en los que 12 mujeres y niñas acusaron a
las tropas rusas de violación dicen que
sólo la punta del iceberg mientras rusia
niega las acusaciones